The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time, we looked
at the case of a Bose gas,
and we found that there
was this condensation
phenomena into the ground state.
Let's go over it one more time.
So the idea was
that when you have
a Bose system, the occupation
of the different one-particle
states, which you can specify
for a non-interacting system
in the grand canonical
ensemble, these entities
are independent for each one
of the one-particle states
and have a form that is related
to the chemical potential
and the energy of these states
through this form, epsilon
[? kd ?] in the
one-particle state,
and z standing for e to the
beta mu, chemical potential
divided by temperature.
OK?
Now, if we go and look
at this in the limit
where z is much
less than 1, which
is appropriate to
high temperatures
or when the case where the
gas is mostly classical,
you can expand this.
You can see that in
the lowest order,
it is z e to the minus
beta epsilon of k.
So it looks like a
standard Boltzmann weight
that we would use in classical
statistical mechanics.
But then there are
higher order terms.
And in particular there
would be a correction
that is e to the minus
beta epsilon of k squared
and so forth that would
modify this result.
But I think this is
something that I mentioned.
If you look at a form such
as this at high temperatures,
it's like a Boltzmann weight.
So the state that has
this lowest energy,
in this case if we
say epsilon of k
is h bar squared k squared
over 2m corresponding to k
equals to 0 for
the lowest energy,
has the highest mean
occupation number of weight.
OK?
Now that is always the case.
This is a function
that, as epsilon of k
becomes larger, no matter
whether you expand it or not,
becomes less and less.
The other limit that
is of interest to us
is how big can z be?
We said that the largest it
can be is when it approaches 1.
And when it is 1, this
quantity, the occupation number,
is e to the beta
epsilon of k minus 1.
Again, something that is
largest as k becomes smaller,
and you go to the lowest energy.
But there is the difficulty that
the one energy that corresponds
to k equals to 0, if I
look at this formula,
it is 1 divided by 0.
It just doesn't
make too much sense.
Now, of course, we
said that typically we
don't want to work
in this variable.
We want to figure out
things as a function
of the number of particles or
the number of particles divided
by volume density, which is
a nice intensive quantity.
OK?
So typically, what should we do?
We said that in the
grand canonical ensemble,
N is the sum over k
these expectation values.
I should really put
an average here,
but we said that in the
thermodynamic sense,
fluctuations being of the
order of square root of N,
we are going to ignore.
So this is what
you would normally
call the number that
we have in the system.
And then you have to replace
this sum in the limit
where we have a large
system with an integral.
So we have the integral
d cubed k 2 pi cubed V.
And then we have this N of k,
which is 1 over z inverse e
to the beta epsilon
of k minus 1.
Now if I go like I did in
the line above to the limit
where z is much less
than 1, then the integral
that I have to do is
simply the integral of z e
to the minus beta epsilon k
h bar squared k squared 2m.
We know what this is.
This is simply, up
to a factor of z,
these are the integrals
that have given me
these factors of 1
over lambda cubed.
Actually, there's
the factor of V
here, so it is V
over lambda cubed.
So normally, you would
then solve for z,
and you would find that z is
the density times lambda cubed.
And this is a formula that we
have seen a number of times,
that the chemical potential
is kt log of n lambda cubed.
OK?
Fine.
But now we are interested
in the other limit.
Now in the other limit,
we have this difficulty
that this quantity, if I look
at it as a function of z,
this is the quantity
that we would
call f-- it is
related to f 3/2 of z.
So this is going to be 1 over
lambda cubed f 3/2 plus of z.
It's a function that increases
with z up to the limiting value
that we are allowed to have,
which is at z equals to 1.
It's a function that starts
linearly, as we have discussed,
but then up here, it comes to
a finite value of zeta 3/2.
OK?
So basically, we know that when
I evaluate this for finite z,
I'm less than where I was here.
So this is certainly less
than 1 over lambda cubed zeta
of 3/2, the limiting value
that we have over here.
So now I have a difficulty.
This function over here,
I can only make it so big.
But I need to make
it big enough so
that I can put enough particles,
the total number of particles
that I have in the system.
So what is happening over here?
What is happening is that when
I make this density larger
and larger, ultimately
when I hit this point at z
equals to 1, as
we have discussed
there is an uncertainty as to
what happens to this expression
when z is equal to 1,
and you are at this state
that corresponds
to k equals to 0.
Right?
I don't know how many
things are over there.
So I can have, in
principle, the freedom
to take advantage of the fact
that I don't know what 1 over 0
is to call that the number
that I need to make up
the difference between
here and there.
OK?
And so, in principle,
when z goes to 1,
then this becomes 1 over lambda
cubed, or V over lambda cubed,
zeta of 3/2, obtained
by essentially
doing the integration
with z equals to 1,
evaluating it at
this possible limit.
And then whatever
is left, I will
put in the k equals to 0 state.
OK?
And you will say, well, what
does that explicitly mean?
Well, what it means is that
I'm really evaluating things
at the value of z that
is extremely close to 1
so that in the thermodynamic
limit where N goes to infinity
I wouldn't know the difference.
But it is really something
that vanishes only
in that thermodynamic limit
of N going to infinity.
And we saw that if I kind
of look at the occupation
number of the k equals
to 0 state, what it is
is z inverse, which is e to
the minus beta mu minus 1.
And if I'm in the limit
where z is very small,
or beta mu is-- sorry, z
is very much close to 1
or beta mu is very small,
then I can expand this.
And this becomes approximately,
when mu goes to 0,
minus 1 over beta mu.
OK?
And I want this
to be the N0, what
is left over when I subtract
from the total number
the amount that I can put
in to the ground state.
OK?
And so you can see that this is
a quantity that is extensive.
It is proportional to
the number of particles.
And mu is the inverse of
that, so it is infinitesimal.
And if I choose that value
of mu that is, essentially,
pushing z infinitesimally
close to 1,
then I can ensure that I have
a finite occupation over there.
OK?
So what does it mean?
If I could actually look at
these occupation numbers,
then I am at temperatures
less than Tc of n.
And we saw that
basically we could
get what the temperature
is when this happens
by equating this combination
g over lambda cubed,
in principle, over-- I
had said g equals to 1.
I could repeat it
with g not equal to 1.
And n, which is g over
lambda cubed zeta of 3/2,
rather than f 3/2 plus,
this defines for me
this temperature Tc of n.
OK?
Now, if I could look at
the occupation numbers
when I was at temperature less
than Tc, what would I see?
I would see that the occupation
number as a function of k
is exactly the form that we
have over here with z equals
to 1, 1 over e to the
beta epsilon of k minus 1.
But then at k
equals to 0, which I
can indicate by some
kind of delta function,
I have everybody else,
which is this N minus
V over lambda cubed zeta of 3/2.
OK?
Actually, let's remember
that our k and momentum
are related to each other.
So rather than asking
what the density is
as a function of this
label k, I can maybe
ask what the density
is for things
that have different momentum P.
And according to
this formula, it
is going to be beta P squared
over 2m, this kind of modified
version of the Boltzmann weight,
and a delta function at P
equals to 0 there.
The rest of the
particles are up here.
Now, when people
saw the signature
of Bose-Einstein condensation,
it was precisely this.
So this is the figure
that shows this
from the experiment of
Eric Cornell and group,
and you see two thermometers.
They are cooling the
temperature of this gas
of atoms that is
confined in a trap.
The way that they
are cooling it is
that they are evaporating away
the high energy particles.
And then the rest
of the particles
are cooled down because they
thermalize, and the highest
energy is always removed.
But in the process,
the density in the trap
is also being reduced.
And if the density goes down,
then Tc of n will also go down.
So what is plotted over here
on the right thermometer
is the Tc of n that you would
calculate from that formula.
And on the right
thermometer is actually
the temperature of the
particles in the gas.
And you can see that
right at some point, then
the Tc of the particles in
the gas goes below Tc of n.
And what is being plotted
over here is as follows.
So you have the
particles that are
in the trap at some temperature.
We remove the trap, and then the
particles are going to escape.
The particles that
have zero momentum
are going to stay
where they are.
The particles that
have large momentum
are going to go further away.
So let's say after one
second you take a picture.
And what you see over
here from the picture
is over here there
are the particles that
had most momentum
and ran further away.
While at the center,
you see the particles
that had small momentum.
You can see that always,
even at high temperature,
the zero momentum is the peak.
But once you go below
this condition of Tc of n,
in addition to the normal
peak that is over here,
you get some additional
peak that is appearing at P
equals to 0, which is
the condensation that you
have into that one single state.
OK?
The other thing that I started
to do last time but let's
complete and finish
today is I wanted
to show you the heat
capacity of this system.
OK.
So how do we do that?
So the first
formula that we had,
the one that I used over here
if I were to divide by V,
is that the density, in general,
is given by g over lambda
cubed f 3/2 plus of z.
OK?
And we said that if
z goes to 1, then I
have to interpret that
appropriately that this
is really just excited
states, and there's
going to be a separation
into the ground
state and the excited states.
So there is really two portions
of n when we are below Tc.
OK?
But then there is also
a formula for pressure.
Beta P was g over
lambda cubed f 5/2 of z.
Again, these f's we had
defined-- f plus m minus 1 of z
was 1 over m minus 1
factorial integral 0
to infinity dx x to the m
minus 1 z inverse e to the x
plus 1-- minus 1.
OK?
Fine.
But in order to calculate
the heat capacity,
I need to work with the energy.
And we said that,
quite generally,
whether you have
classical system,
quantum gas, bosons, fermions,
the energy and pressure
are related simply by this
formula, which is ultimately
a consequence of the scaling of
the energy being proportional
to momentum squared
that we have over there.
OK?
So let's look at this formula.
What do I have?
For T that is less than Tc
of n, my z is equal to 1.
Pressure comes
entirely from particles
that are moving around.
So although the density
breaks into two components,
in principle I guess I would
say that the pressure also
breaks into two components.
But the component that
is at k equals to 0
is not moving around.
It is not giving you any
contribution to the pressure.
So what do we?
We have P is kt, taking
the beta to the other side.
I have g over lambda cubed, and
then this f plus evaluated at z
equals to 1, which is
this zeta function of 5/2.
OK?
So fine.
So what do I have for energy?
Energy is going to be at
3/2 V times this formula,
kd T g over lambda
cubed zeta 5/2.
And I noticed that lambda, being
h square root of 2 pi mk T,
scales like T to the minus 1/2.
So 1 over lambda cubed
scales like T to the 3/2 plus
this is something that's
scaling like T to the 5/2.
And this is simply proportional
to the volume and temperature
to the [INAUDIBLE] fifth power.
It knows nothing
about the density.
Why?
Because if you were at the
same temperature and volume,
put more particle
in the system, all
of those additional
particles would go over here,
would make no contribution
to pressure or to energy.
You wouldn't see them.
So once you have this, the heat
capacity at constant volume,
dE by dT, is simply 5 over
2T of whatever energy is.
And there is a reason that
I write it in this fashion.
So what you would
say is that if I
were to plot the heat
capacity at constant volume
as a function of
temperature, well,
it's natural units are
of the order of kB.
You can see that this T and
this T I can cancel out.
So I have something
that has units of kB.
It is extensive
proportional to volume.
I can really certainly
write it in this fashion.
And what I have
is that the curve
behaves like T to the 3/2.
So this is proportional
to T to the 3/2.
And presumably, this behavior
continues all the way
until the temperature at
which this system ceases
to be a Bose-Einstein
condensate.
So the low temperature form of
the heat capacity's calculation
is very simple.
Now, at very high
temperatures, we
know that the heat capacity is
going to be 3/2 N kT, right?
So ultimately, I know that if
I go to very high temperatures,
my heat capacity is
going to be 3/2 N,
if I divide it by [? kB. ?] OK?
Now, there is a reason
that I drew this line
over here less
than the peak here.
Well, in order to calculate
the heat capacity on this side,
we'll have to do a
little bit more work.
You can no longer assume
that z equals to 1.
z is something
that is less than 1
that is obtained by
solving N equals to g over
lambda cubed f 3/2 plus of z.
OK?
But I can still presumably
use these formulae.
I have that the
energy is 3/2 PV.
So I have V kT times--
what is the thing
that I have on the
right-hand side?
It is g over lambda cubed,
just as I have over here
except that I have to
put f 5/2 plus of z.
OK?
And if I want to calculate
the heat capacity, what
I need to do is to
take a derivative
of the energy with
respect to temperature.
And then I notice, well,
again, right like I had before,
whatever appears here is
proportional to T to the 5/2.
So when I take a derivative
with respect to temperature,
I essentially get 5/2 this
whole quantity divided by T.
So just like I had over
here, I will write the result
as 3/2 V kT g over lambda cubed.
And then I have the 5/2 1
over T of f 5/2 plus of z.
But you say that's the
wrong way of doing things
because in addition to this
combination out front be
explicitly proportional
to T to the 5/2 power,
this factor z here is implicitly
a function of temperature
because it is related to density
through that formula N equals
to g over lambda
cubed f 5/2 plus of z.
So you should not forget to
take the derivative of what
is over here with
respect to T. OK?
So what do I get when I take a
derivative of this with respect
to T?
Well, the argument
is not T, it is z.
So I will have to
take a dz by dT,
and then the derivative of
f 5/2 with respect to z.
And we saw that one
of the characteristics
of these functions
was that when we
took the derivative
of each one of them,
we generated one with
a lower argument.
So the derivative would
be f 3/2 plus of z.
But in order to have this
[? latter ?] property,
I had to do a z d by
dz, and so I essentially
need to restore
this 1 over z here.
So you can see that, really,
the difference between what
I had at low temperatures
and high temperatures,
at low temperatures this was
just a number that I was using
over here, zeta of
5/2, and I didn't
have to bother about
this other term.
Now, we can figure out what
the behavior of this term
is certainly at
small z because we
have the expansion of
these functions at small z.
And if you do sufficient
work, you will find-- well,
first of all, at the
largest values of z-- sorry,
at the smallest
value, z going to 0,
you can confirm that the heat
capacity in units of N kB
is simply 3/2.
So you will come to
this line over here,
and then the first correction
that you calculate you'll find
is going to take you
in that direction.
Actually, if you do the
calculation for bosons
and fermions at
high temperatures,
you can convince yourself
that while bosons
will go in this direction,
fermions, the heat capacity,
will start to go in
the other direction.
But OK, so you
have this behavior.
And then what we
haven't established
and the reason that I'm still
doing all of this algebra
is that, OK, this
curve is going up,
where is it going to end up?
Is it going to
end up here, here,
or right where this curve hits?
OK?
And what I will show
you is that this
has to end up right
at this point.
And actually, in order to
show that, all we need to do
is to figure out what these
terms do when I evaluate them
at z equals to 1.
And because these
things are telling
me what is happening as I am
approaching to this point,
the question that I ask is,
what is the limiting behavior
of this function as I
get to z equals to 1?
But the limiting value
of this one I know.
It is precisely what
I want over here.
It is zeta of 5/2.
So I have to somehow show
you that this next term is 0.
Well, this next term,
however, depends on dz by dT.
How can I get that?
Well, all of these things
are done under the conditions
where the volume is fixed,
or the number of particles
is fixed, if the
density is fixed.
So z and T are related
through the formula that
says N over V, which
is the density,
is g over lambda
cubed f 3/2 plus of z.
OK?
So if I take the system and
I change its temperature,
while keeping the number
of particles, volume,
fixed so that the
density is fixed,
if I take d by dT on both
sides, on the other side
I'm assuming that I'm doing the
calculations under conditions
where the density
does not change.
And then what do
I have over here?
I have to take the temperature
derivative of this.
There's an implicit
derivative here
since this is T to the
3/2 proportionately.
So when I take a derivative,
I will get 3 over 2T,
and then I will have
f 3/2 plus of z.
But then I have to take
the derivative that
is implicit in the
dependence on z here.
And that's going to
be identical to this,
except that when I take
a derivative of f 3/2,
I will generate f 1/2 of z.
OK?
So since the left-hand
side is equal to 0,
I can immediately
solve for this,
and I find that T
dz by dT 1 over z
is minus 3/2 f 3/2 plus of z
divided by f 1/2 plus of z.
OK?
So essentially, what I can do
is I can multiply through by T.
So this T will get rid of this
T. I can bring a T, therefore,
here.
And this combination
over here I can
replace from what I have there
with minus 3/2 f 3/2 plus of z
divided by f 1/2 half plus of z.
Why is any of this useful?
Well, it immediately gives
the answer that I need.
Why?
Because f 1/2 is the
derivative of this function.
And you can see that
I drew it so that it
has infinite derivative
when z hits 1.
And we had indeed said that
this function zeta of m, which
is the limit of this
when z goes to 1,
only exists for m
that is larger than 1,
and it is divergent for
m that is less than 1.
So when z hits 1, this
thing goes to infinity,
and the fraction disappears.
And so basically, the
additional correction
that you have beyond this
becoming zeta of 5/2,
which is what we have
over here, vanishes.
So I have shown that, indeed,
whatever this curve is doing,
it will hit that point
exactly at Tc of n
at the same height as the
low temperature curve.
And you can do a certain
amount of work and algebra
to show that it goes
there with a finite slope.
So that's the shape
of the heat capacity
curve for the
Bose-Einstein condensate.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it seems that
f 1/2 goes to infinity,
but it's [? on ?] the
half, so it is half
comes from the [INAUDIBLE] 3.
So--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: --you have higher
dimensional system, then
it seems that [INAUDIBLE] won't
vanish there. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if you have a
higher dimensional system,
indeed the situation
would be different.
And I guess the borderline
dimension would need to be--
since this is a V
over 2 minus 1--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: V over
2 minus 1 being 1,
which is the borderline,
will give you a dc of 4.
So something else
happens above 4.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it seems that
the nature of this phase
transition, indeed it
changes with the dimension.
PROFESSOR: Exactly, yes.
The nature of this
phase transition
does depend on [INAUDIBLE].
Good.
OK?
So we will come back to
this heat capacity curve
a little bit later
because I want
to now change directions
and not talk about
Bose-Einstein condensation
anymore, but about a phenomena
that is much more
miraculous in my view,
and that is superfluidity.
So the first thing that is
very interesting about helium
is its phase diagram.
So we are used to
drawing phase diagrams
as a function of
pressure and temperature,
which have a separation
between a liquid and a gas
that terminates at
a critical point.
So we have seen something
like this many times, where
you have on the low
pressure/high temperature
side a gas.
On the higher pressure/lower
temperature side,
you have a liquid.
And they terminate, this line
of coexistence between the two
of them, at a critical point.
And for the case of
helium, the critical point
occurs roughly at
5.2 degrees Kelvin
and something like
2.6 atmospheres.
OK?
So far, nothing different from,
say, liquid water, for example,
and steam, except that
for all other substances,
when we cool it at the
low enough temperatures,
we go past the triple point,
and then we have a solid phase.
For the case of
helium, it stays liquid
all the way down
to 0 temperature.
If you put sufficiently
high pressure on it,
ultimately it will
become a solid.
But at normal pressures--
so this maximal pressure
is something of the
order of 26 atmosphere.
For pressures that are
less than 26 atmosphere,
you can cool the liquid all
the way down to 0 temperature,
and it stays happily a liquid.
So let's think about
why that is the case.
Well, why do things typically
become solids anyway?
The reason is that if I
think about the interaction
that I have between two objects,
two atoms and molecules,
we have discussed
this in connection
with condensation
before that what
we have is that at
very large separations
there is a van der
Waals' attraction.
Typically, the dipole
moments of these atoms
would be fluctuating, and the
fluctuations would somehow
align them temporarily
in the manner
that the energy can be reduced.
At very short distances, the
electronic clouds will overlap,
and so you would have
something such as this.
And then, typically, you
will have the function that
joins them and look
something like this.
OK?
And this is no different
for the case of helium.
You have here essentially
a hard core appearing
at the distance that is of
the order of 2.6 angstroms.
There is a minimum that is
of the order of 3 angstroms.
Now, the depth of this potential
is not very big for helium.
It is only of the order
of, say, 9 degrees Kelvin.
And the reason is that the
strength of this van der Waals'
attraction is proportional
to the polarizability that
scales typically with
the number of electrons
that you have in your atom.
And so it is, in
fact, proportional
to your atomic number squared.
And with the
exception of hydrogen,
this is going to be
the smallest value
that you are going to get for
the van der Waals' attraction.
And hydrogen does not count
because it forms a molecule.
So helium does not
form a molecule.
You have these [? balls. ?]
They have these attractions.
Now, typically
things become solid
as you go to 0
temperature is because you
can find the minimum energy
in which you put everybody
at the minimum
energy separation.
So you form a lattice.
Everybody is around
this separation,
and they're all happy and that
solid minimizes the energy.
So why doesn't helium
do the same thing?
Maybe it should just do
it at a lower temperature
because the scale
of this is lower.
Again, the reason
it doesn't do that
is because of quantum mechanics.
Because you can
say that, really,
I cannot specify exactly where
the particle are because that
would violate quantum mechanics.
There has to be some
uncertainty delta x.
And associated
with delta x there
is going to be some kind of
a typical momentum, which
is h bar over delta x.
And there will be
some contribution
to the kinetic
energy of particles
due to this uncertainty in
delta x that is of this form.
And if I make the
localization more precise,
I have to pay a higher
cost in kinetic energy.
Well, presumably the
scale of the energies
that I can tolerate and still
keep these things localized
is of the order of this
binding energy, which
is of the order of, as we
said, 9 or 10 degrees Kelvin.
Let's say 10 degrees Kelvin.
OK?
Now, the other property
that distinguishes helium
from krypton and, let's say,
all the other noble gases
is that its mass is very small.
So because this mass is small,
this uncertainty in energy
becomes comparatively larger.
OK?
And so if you put the
mass of the helium here
and you use this
value of 10 degrees
K converted to the
appropriate energy units,
you ask what kind
of a delta x would
be compatible with this
kind of binding energy,
you find that the
delta x that you get
is of the order
of 0.5 angstroms.
OK?
So basically, you cannot
keep this in the bottom
of the potential if you have
uncertainty that is of this
order.
So the atoms of helium cannot
form a nice lattice and stay
in order because that registry
would violate the quantum
uncertainty principle.
They are moving around.
And so you have
a system that has
been [? melted ?] due
to quantum fluctuations
rather than thermal
fluctuations.
OK?
So that's all nice,
except that something
does happen when
you cool helium.
And actually, it is interesting
that helium provides us
not only with one liquid that
persists all the way to 0
temperature, but two
liquids because helium
has two isotopes.
There is helium-4, which
is the abundant one,
and there is helium-3, which is
a much less available isotope.
But the number of
protons being different
in the nucleus of these means
that helium-4 is a boson,
while helium-3 is fermion.
So we have the opportunity to
observe both a Bose system that
is liquid at low
temperature and a Fermi
liquid at [INAUDIBLE]
temperatures.
Now, the case of
the Fermi liquid
is not really that
different in principle
from the Fermi liquid of
the electrons in copper
that we already discussed.
There are some subtleties.
In the case of the
bosons, [? well, ?]
we saw that for bosons
there is potentially
this kind of phase transition.
In reality, what
happens is that helium
has a transition
between two forms
of the liquid at
a temperature that
is of the order of
2.18 degrees Kelvin.
So we can call this helium
I and this helium II,
OK, two different forms of the
helium-4 liquid that you have.
So how was this
seen experimentally?
I kind of told you how
in these experiments
of the Bose-Einstein
condensation,
part of the way that
they cooled the system
was to remove the
high-energy particles,
and the remaining
particles cooled down.
So that's the common
method that actually people
use for cooling various things.
It's called evaporative--
evaporative cooling.
And for the case of helium, it
is actually reasonably simple
to draw what it is.
You have a bath that is full
of helium that is reasonably
nicely thermally isolated
from the environment.
So you want to cool it,
remove the energy from it.
And the thing that you do
is you pump out the gas.
OK?
So this is a coexistence
because this part
up here on top of the
liquid helium is not vacuum.
What happens is that there
is evaporation of helium,
leaving the liquid and
going into the gas.
And once they are in the
gas, they are pumped out.
But every time you
grab a helium from here
to put it into the gas,
you've essentially taken it
from down here and
moved it to infinity,
so you lose this amount
of binding energy.
It's called latent heat.
Essentially, this
is the latent heat,
and it is actually of
the order of 7 degrees
Kelvin because
typically it has to be
the depth of the typical
positions of these particles.
OK?
So for each atom
that you pump out,
you have reduced
the total energy
that you have in the liquid,
and the liquid cools down.
And what is the trajectory?
You always actually remain
on this coexistence line.
The pressure is changing.
The temperature is lowering.
But you're always remaining
on the coexistence
of the gas and liquid line.
So you follow what is
happening over here,
and you find that as you
are approaching here,
suddenly this system
starts to bubble up.
It is just like having a
kettle that is boiling.
Indeed, it is, again, in
like the case of kettle,
there are these bubbles that
are carrying the steam that
is going to go over here
and being pulled out,
and so it is bubbling.
And then suddenly, [INAUDIBLE]
heat 2.18 degrees Kelvin,
and the whole thing quiets down.
And below that, it stays quiet.
And so let's see if
we can show that.
We saw the phase diagram.
So this is the liquid.
Let's see if we can
get the sound also.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[INAUDIBLE].
This rapid [INAUDIBLE]
evaporates [INAUDIBLE]
helium cools, until at 2
degrees above absolute 0,
a dramatic transformation
takes place.
Suddenly, we see--
PROFESSOR: Everything quiets.
--[INAUDIBLE] stops and that the
surface of the liquid helium is
completely still.
The temperature is actually
being lowered even further now,
but nothing is happening.
Well, this is really one
of the great phenomenon
in 20th-century physics.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I'll show you this movie
at the next lecture.
But this is just a
segment of it that
shows the important property
of this fluid, helium II, which
is the superfluid.
So now you're above the
temperature it was boiling,
but it quieted down.
You can see that
the fluid started
to go through the
capillaries that
were at the bottom of this.
So at the bottom of this glass
there were fine capillaries.
As long as you were up
here, the capillaries
were sufficient to
keep the fluid above.
Once you went below,
the fluid went through
as if there is no resistance.
And that's the
superfluid property.
-Superfluidity and
superconductivity were baffling
concepts for scien--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, we'll
go back to that later.
So let's list some
of the properties
of this superfluid state.
OK.
So what this last
experiment showed
is that it appears to
have zero viscosity.
So what's the way that
you would calculate
the viscosity of a fluid?
And one way to sort
of do that relies on
like what we had over
here, passing the fluid
through some pore or capillary.
In the case of this
experiment, you
have to really make this
capillary extremely fine
so that practically
nothing will go through it.
But this could be
a quite general way
of measuring viscosity
of some fluid.
So you have some fluid.
You can measure its
viscosity by trying
to pass it through a
capillary by exerting pressure
on one side and measuring,
in essence, the difference
between the two pressures
that you have on the two sides
as a measure of the force
that you are exerting on this.
And once you do that,
then these pistons enhance
the velocity--
sorry, the fluid, are
moving through with
some kind of velocity.
And some measure of
viscosity, after you
divide by various things that
have dimensions of length
and pressure, et
cetera, would be related
to the velocity
divided by delta P--
is to achieve the same velocity,
how much pressure difference
you have to put.
Now, for this experiment
of superfluid helium,
you'll find that essentially
you can get a finite velocity
by typically infinitesimal
pressure difference.
So when you try to use this
method to calculate viscosity,
you find that, to whatever
precision you can measure,
essentially this value of eta
is not distinguishable from 0.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The way you defined
it, it would be infinity?
PROFESSOR: Then I
probably defined it--
[? no? ?] Delta P goes to 0 for
a finite V. Yes, so viscosity--
AUDIENCE: So what
you're essentially
writing is the
Reynolds number, yeah?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: All right?
But there is another
experiment that
appears to indicate that
there is a finite viscosity,
and that is a famous experiment
due to Andronikashvili.
And basically, this is
the other experiment.
You imagine that you put your
fluid inside a container.
And then you insert in this
container a set of plates,
could be copper plates
or something else,
that are stacked on
top of each other.
So essentially, you have a
stack of these plates that
have a common axis,
and there's a rod
that is going through them.
And what you created here
is a torsional oscillator
in the sense that this rod
that holds all of these things
together has a particular
preferred orientation.
And if you start, let's
say-- well, it may or may not
have a particular orientation--
but if you start to rotate it,
it will certainly have
a moment of inertia that
resists the rotation that is
coming from all of the plates
if it was in vacuum.
So if I could measure the moment
of inertia of these objects,
either through torsion
or some other mechanism,
if it is a torsional
oscillator I
could figure out what
the frequency is.
If I knew the
[? spinning ?] constant
that wants to bring the angle
to some particular value,
I would divide that by
the moment of inertia.
The square root of that
would give me the frequency.
So the frequency is a measure
of the moment of inertia.
So if I had this
thing in vacuum,
I could figure out
what the moment
of inertia of all
of the plates was.
Now, if I add the fluid to this,
then as I start to rotate this,
some of the fluid will
certainly move with the plates.
And so the moment of inertia
that you would measure
in the presence of
the fluid is larger
than it is in the
absence of fluid.
And that additional
moment of inertia
tells you about how much of
the fluid is, in some sense,
stuck to the plates, and that's
another different measure
of the viscosity.
OK?
So if we sort of look
at this experiment,
we would imagine that if I
measure the moment of inertia
as a function of
temperature, something
should happen when I hit Tc.
Above Tc, I'm getting some value
that is measuring, essentially,
the moment of inertia of
the plates plus the fluid
that is moving
around, [? we do. ?]
But what happens
when you hit Tc?
If the superfluid doesn't
care about things around it,
you would imagine that this
would drop down to the value
that it has in vacuum.
In reality, what it does
is something like this.
So it does go to
the value that you
would have in vacuum but
only at 0 temperature.
So at any finite
temperature we know Tc.
There is indeed some
fraction of the superfluid
that is trapped by these plates.
So what's happening?
OK, so this is one [INAUDIBLE].
The other property-- maybe I
will squeeze it somewhere here.
There are a whole
bunch of things
that indicate that there is a
coupling between temperature
and mechanical properties,
so-called thermo-mechanical
couplings.
What you find in this
experiment, where
the fluid spontaneously
goes, let's
say, from this
side to this side,
so the direction
is like this, is
that when you measure
the temperatures
you will find that the
temperature of this one
goes up, and the temperature
of this one goes down.
So somehow the motion led to
some temperature differences.
A dramatic one that, again,
maybe we'll show in the movie
next time is the
fountain effect.
What you do is you--
let's imagine that,
again, you have a vat of
helium, and inside of it
you put a tube that is,
let's say, shaped like this.
And you have the fluid that
is occupying everything here.
Then inside this tube,
you put some material
that is a good absorber of
heat, such as, let's say,
a piece of carbon, and
then you shine laser
on it so that this
thing becomes hot.
So in this case, the
temperature goes up,
and what you find happens
is that the fluid will
start to shoot up
here like a fountain.
It's called the fountain
effect because of that.
And essentially, whereas
here pressure was converted
to temperature, here
temperature, the heating,
gets converted to pressure.
So this is like-- I
don't know if you've ever
done this, where you put
your hand under water,
and if you squeeze your hand
and the water shoots up.
So it's kind of putting pressure
here, causing a fountain that
is shooting up like that.
OK?
So there is this coupling
between temperature
and-- actually, this issue
of boiling-not boiling
is also a manifestation of a
coupling between temperature
and mechanical properties, which
is whether the fluid is boiling
or not boiling.
OK?
So given everything that we
have been talking about so far,
it is tempting to
imagine that there
is a connection
between all of this
and the Bose-Einstein
condensation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do superfluids have
no vorticity or can they?
PROFESSOR: Yes, they
can have vorticity,
but it is of a special kind.
It is quantized vorticity.
And so what you can certainly do
is you can take a vat of helium
and set it into
rotation, and then you
will create vortex lines
inside this superfluid.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I was wondering if
there was an analogy
to superconductivity
and magnetic fields.
PROFESSOR: The analog of the
magnetic field is the rotation.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So in
that sense, yes.
OK?
OK.
So similarities between BEC,
Bose-Einstein Condensation,
and superfluidity.
I would say that perhaps the
most important one, although I
guess at the beginning of
the story they didn't know
this one, is that helium-3,
which is a fermion,
does not become superfluid
around this same temperature
of 2 degrees Kelvin,
which is where
helium-4 becomes superfluid.
What is special about
this is, well, you
would say that once you
have mass and density,
you can figure out what the
Bose-Einstein temperature is.
You had this formula
that was n lambda
cubed is equal to zeta of 3/2.
So that gives you some
value of kB Tc being h
squared 2 pi mass of helium,
and then you have a zeta of 3/2
and n somewhere.
3-- I guess this n-- oops,
n-- yeah, it's correct-- n h
cubed 2 pi m kB Tc to the
3/2 being zeta of 3/2.
So 2 pi m kB Tc is
proportional to n zeta of 3/2
to the 2/3 power.
OK.
So I had a picture here, which
was the typical attraction
potential.
The typical separation
of helium atoms
is something like 3.6 angstroms.
How do I know that is because
the density I can figure out
is typically 1 over the
volume per particle,
and this volume per particle
is roughly 3.6 angstroms cubed.
It's something like
46.2 angstrom cubed.
So I can put that
value of n over here.
I know what the
mass of helium is.
And I can figure
out what this Tc is,
and I find that Tc is 3.13
degrees K. You say, well, it's
not exactly the 2 pi and
something that we had.
But given that we completely
ignored the interactions
that we have between this,
and this is the result
that we have for
[? point ?] particles
of mass m with no interactions,
this is actually very good.
You would say, OK, this is
roughly in the right range.
And presumably if
I were to include
the effects of
interactions, potentially I
will get an interaction,
temperature,
that is roughly correct.
So this is another reason.
The third reason is that
you have automatically,
when you are talking about the
Bose-Einstein condensation,
a relationship between
pressure and temperature.
So remember the
formula that we had
for the Bose-Einstein
condensation,
beta P was something,
where P is kT
1 over lambda cubed
zeta of 5/2, right?
So once you specify
the temperature,
you've also specified
the pressure.
They go hand in hand.
So then you can start to explain
a lot of these phenomena,
such as here you
increase the temperature,
pressure had to go up, and
it was the increased pressure
than did that.
It kind of tells you
something about what
is going on in this
experiment over here,
where the temperature goes up
where you have higher pressure.
It actually also
explains why things
stop bubbling when you
go into the superfluid.
Because let's back
out and think of why
things are bubbling when you put
your kettle on top of the oven.
And the reason is that there
are variations in temperature.
There could be a local
hotspot over here,
and in this local
hotspot, eventually there
will a bubble that forms,
and the bubble goes away.
Why is it that it forms here
is because heat gets spread out
through diffusion.
If I strike a match or even
if I have a blow torch here,
you won't feel the
heat for some time.
But if I do this, you
hear my hand clapping
much more rapidly.
So pressure gets transmitted
very efficiently through sound,
whereas heat goes very
slowly through diffusion.
And that's why when you
boil something, essentially
you will have the diffusion of
heat, local hotspots, bubbles.
But if temperature changes are
connected to pressure changes,
then for the superfluid,
having a local hotspot
is like doing this.
It creates immediately
a pressure change,
and pressure changes
are rapidly taken away.
And that's why this
could also explain
what's going on over here.
So I think this number two was
first noted by Fritz London.
Maybe we'll talk about that
a bit more next time around.
Based on all of
these similarities,
Laszlo Tisza, who
spent many years at MIT
after being in Europe,
proposed the two-fluid model.
So again, roughly
inspired by what
we saw for the case of the
Bose-Einstein condensate,
we saw that for the
below Tc you had to
make a separation
for the number of things that
were in the ground state,
k equals to 0, and
all of the others
that were in the
higher excited states.
Pressure, heat
capacity, everything
came from the excited component,
whereas the component that
was at the k equals to 0 state
was not making any contribution
to these phenomena.
So what he proposed
was that somehow,
again, similarly when you
are in the superfluid,
you really have two
components, two fluids
that are in coexistence.
There is a superfluid
component, and there
is a normal component.
And as you change temperature,
these two components
get converted to each other.
So just like the case of the
Bose-Einstein condensate,
it is not like you have
so many of this fluid, so
many of that fluid.
These two things are
always interchanging.
And then what is happening
in this experiment,
presumably, is that the
superfluid component
goes through, the normal
component leaves behind.
The superfluid component is the
component that, in some sense,
has less entropy, is
at lower temperature.
So when it goes here,
it cools down this part.
This part then goes
up in temperature.
Again, there is no way that you
can push all of the superfluid
here and have normal here
because these things get
converted.
So some amount of superfluid
goes through here.
Some amount gets converted
from the normal back
to the superfluid.
So there is this exchange
that is constantly
taking place in the system.
And so on the basis of
this model and having
different velocities for
the normal and superfluid
component, Tisza could explain
a number of these things.
OK?
So I will mention some
important differences
at the end of this lecture
and leave their resolution
for next.
So while those were similarities
between BEC and superfluidity,
there are very
important differences.
One important
observation immediately
is that if I try to compress
superfluid helium or normal
helium, it doesn't matter.
It is just like
trying to compress
any other fluid such as water.
It does not like to be squeezed.
So helium liquid is
approximately, of course
not entirely,
incompressible, while BEC, we
saw that the pressure is only
a function of temperature.
It doesn't know anything
about the density.
So you can change the density.
All of the additional
particles will
go to go to the k
equals to 0 state.
It doesn't really care.
So BEC is infinitely
compressible.
And of course,
this is immediately
a manifestation of
the interactions.
In the case of the BEC, we
didn't put any interactions
among the particles.
We can put as many of them as
we like into the single state k
equals to 0.
Of course, real heliums,
they have the self-avoiding--
the interaction between them.
They cannot go
[? through ?] each other.
So that's an
important difference.
Number 2 is that detailed
shapes/ T dependences of heat
capacity and density of the
superfluid part are different.
OK.
So I have up there what
the heat capacity of a BEC
should look like.
Now, people have measured
the heat capacity of helium
as a function of temperature,
and something does indeed
happen at Tc.
And what you find the shape
is is something like this.
It goes to 0, and then it
does something like this.
And so while it doesn't look
that different from what
I have up there, except that
when you look at the behavior
down here, at the
transition, over there
it went to a finite value.
Here it diverges as a log.
So when you go to Tc, it
actually goes to infinity.
And because of the
shape that this has,
this is sometimes called
the lambda transition.
Now, there's lots of issues
about interesting things
happening at the
transition, and we
won't be able to resolve that.
But one thing that we should
be able to figure out,
based on what we know
already, is the behavior
as things go to 0 temperature.
And I said that for the
Bose-Einstein condensate,
the temperature dependence
is T to the 3/2.
What is important is
that for the superfluid,
it is actually
proportional to T cubed.
And T cubed, if you
go back in the course,
is a signature of what
was happening for phonons.
So Landau looked
at this and said
there must be some kind of a
phonon-like excitation going
on, which is different from this
case [INAUDIBLE] excitations
that we have.
The other thing that
we had was that if we
look at the fraction that is
in-- let's say the density that
is in the k equals to 0 state as
a function of temperature, what
happens for the
superfluid-- sorry,
what happens for the
Bose-Einstein condensate--
for the Bose-Einstein
condensate,
let's use the
green-- essentially,
the curve will come down to Tc
linearly, and then it goes up,
and it reaches its
asymptotic value.
From this result, the
fraction that is excited,
the difference to 1
is proportional to 1
over lambda cubed.
So this goes like T to the 3/2.
You can ask whether what was
observed in the Andronikashvili
experiment, eventually
this measure
also, the fraction that is
in the superfluid component
or excited states, does
this curve match that curve?
But if I take this curve and
put it over here, first of all,
down here it is different.
It goes like Tc minus T to the
2/3 power rather than linear
that you have over here.
That, again, is less
[? worry ?] than the fact
that over here it goes
to 0 proportional to T
to the fourth.
Again, something that
needs explanation.
And finally, I will
write down one statement,
and then maybe we'll
explain next time,
is that BEC with the
spectrum of excitations,
which is k squared over
2m, cannot be superfluid.
There is an interesting reason
for that that we will explain.
And indeed, we'll see
that having excitations
that are [INAUDIBLE] like is
compatible with superfluidity.
This kind of excitation is not.
So why is that, et cetera,
we'll talk about next time.